like a lot of people i was upset when
jake paul knocked out ben askren
rather i was more upset that ben lost
than jake paul won
there's a difference between the two
things the fight definitely caught the
public's imagination
the question is why i think there was
more going on this fight than meets the
eye
and what was going on was the key
dynamic of pitting
internet culture versus real world
culture disruption
versus the establishment it's only in
this era of social media influencers
where a youtube personality
who happens to take a serious interest
in boxing can command the viewership and
kind of money
that would traditionally only be
reserved for boxers of the stature of
the greatest of all time like
floyd mayweather or mike tyson the paul
brothers have found a certain angle of
attack into combat sports
that is uniquely their own which
completely disregards the time-honored
traditional
gatekeepers rites of passage and
existing hierarchy structures
urai hal's response when asked what he
thinks of jake paul
sums up the duality of what jake paul
has done working my ass off
literally dying this [ __ ] just
comes out there says a couple of [ __ ]
and i know what he's doing he
let's be honest the guy sucks he sucks
he really sucks and look who's picking
so i get it you know from a business
standpoint a youtube fighter going out
there and
or a youtube person just going out there
and people are feeding off that because
you have people that hate him and you
have people that love him but you still
gotta watch him
it's genius but at the same time it's
like
it humiliates what i call real athletes
that really put in the time and i know
guys behind me not even making that much
i know guys out there that aren't making
much than the ring card girls
jake paul is the epitome of a chaos
agent bringing
deeply ambivalent change change that is
both
helpful and harmful like the advantages
of technology itself it isn't clear
whether this change will be good or bad
for society overall
think about the incredible changes
across the globe born on by accelerating
disruptions due to technology
uber airbnb amazon to name just a few
and more recently gamestop and the whole
phenomenon
nfts jake paul comes from this world
a world that is a world that few
ordinary people truly understand
against this tide stood ben askren
someone we could understand
i think people tuned into this fight
more to see ben askren than to see jake
paul
and this interest is clearly reflected
in the numbers
shortly before the fight ben askren's
appearance on
logan paul's podcast had nearly twice
the views of the appearance of
logan paul's own brother jake paul
that's quite notable
people identified with ben not because
everyone has achieved the high level of
accomplishment he has
but more because his overall attitude
and confidence represents
a sort of prevailing moral order
ben askren was the embodiment of the way
things work
rather the way things should work that
is
there is no shortcuts to success only
hard work
sacrifice respect hardship and time
every compelling fight is over an
uncertain outcome
each side has its pros and cons ben
despite not being a boxer
relied on his inner grit and mental
toughness
this toughness born from hardship was at
the heart of the argument of those who
thought that he would
easily defeat jake paul and you can see
this in ben's own assessment
you know everyone who's like a real
fighter they understand and this is
whether like i would even consider like
wrestlers fighters or
maybe jiu jitsu right anyone will say
combat athlete but
they've been they understand what it's
like to really be a fighter they
understand what it's like to go through
hard circumstances
and battle adversity and deal with it
they understand that thing
that toughness jake paul is a little
boy he is some rich celebrity who wants
to pretend he is a fighter
by fighting guys who are really bad i
mean we identified with ben
because ben's inner stability and
confidence was reassuring against this
agent of chaos
jake paul and what was so upsetting was
that that inner stability wasn't enough
to win you every fight
and that was a shock that a man who was
able to come back from the dead against
robbie lawler was not able to take a 1-2
from jake paul
the two events just did not exist in the
hierarchy that we expected
we don't live in that kind of world
after the fight
i consumed a lot of fight reaction
content i watched daniel cormier's
reaction which was very satisfying
and i looked at other people's reactions
all these people who had all these
theories and compelling arguments on why
ben would win
it all seemed so certain and when he got
ko'd it was like there was no certainty
anymore
it was like the movie no country for old
men which is about the loss of order in
the face of chaos
and it was a very depressing conclusion
however
what i did take away afterwards was a
little different and i didn't take it
away
until i saw ben's interview with aero
homani two days after the fight
in the last segment of the interview
ariel asks him if he thinks the ko will
affect his legacy and ben
says legacy is stupid legacy is
something that people
shouldn't really be concerned about um
because you should just be worried about
what you're doing on a day-to-day basis
like moving forward i'm gonna keep
trying to coach and make kids and change
the main lives as i can
and and if i somehow long term achieve
something if people want to think back
on me favorably or unfavorably then
they're going to do that but you can't
determine what other people think
and you can't let what other people
think dictate your actions
and so i've already told you i i think
legacy is a relatively
stupid concept um from from a self
perspective like i'm gonna do this
because of my legacy
i think that's that's a really negative
thing for people
to actually think about so i try not to
think about it ever for myself
so you but you don't sit back and say
like man you know when i'm 60
is this going to be the first line or is
this going to be the foot
ever ever that's good because you
shouldn't
you really shouldn't it's it's it's
counterproductive to your current life
to think about
what people what people may think of you
in your future life
and just like literally do do what you
want to do in your in your
current life and if it fits your morals
and standards
and if you can stand by it then stand by
it and if you think you should be doing
other things then go do other things
and that's it but um to think of what is
someone going to think of me in 30 years
that's kind of productive
and you can see how from this kind of
thinking he was the person who was able
to go
lose to a youtuber and not give a [ __ ]
take the money and deal with the
embarrassment
a week before his fight with jake paul
ben appeared on logan paul's podcast
which is like going to the heart of the
enemy culture he's fighting
and i think to everyone's surprise they
actually had a nice podcast everyone got
along
it was very entertaining they had good
energy and
at a certain point logan asked him point
blank
are you nervous facing someone who's not
a traditional fighter what what is that
i don't know i mean i don't know why i'd
be nervous
about that um i think that that should
make me less nervous
no because if you lose i mean dog i'll
just say it's over
it's over [ __ ] man what do you mean i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go back i'm gonna run
my wrestling academy
my life is not really gonna change a few
13 year olds are going to tease me a
little bit
like how it sucks dude's bulletproof
oh my god logan i don't know your life
that well i'm sure there's something
you've done that you
damn there's gonna be some stuff that's
embarrassing listen you just get over it
you live your life i'm gonna run my
wrestling campaigns the same day
i tell kids you know when when they're
nervous about a big match
i tell them listen man i had the most
embarrassing knockout that's ever
happened
in mma history i'm the same guy july 7th
as i was july 5th
what do you just shake it off and you
keep moving unreal
i mean listen he's absolutely right he's
absolutely right he's so happy all the
time
you can see how on the one hand that
lack of fire in him also contributed to
him losing the fight
yet he did exactly what he said he would
do
make some money then move on and focus
on the things that are actually
important to them
he mentions this in the hawaii interview
because you should just be worried about
what you're doing on a
day-to-day basis like moving forward
i'm going to keep trying to coach and
make kids and change the main lives as i
can
this is a mission oriented mindset of a
mature person with a greater mission
than himself
aside from the internet versus
real-world dynamic one of the most
compelling features of this fight
is the immature versus mature man
dynamic
here you have this immature young man
who is challenging an older
mature man who is more grounded and you
can
really get to see the differences
between the two approaches
one of the things ben said was if the
guy's a good boxer i'm gonna lose
um i had started there was a certain
fear he had around me
um and i was starting to get the feeling
that maybe he's not very good
like why why is he so nervous and
worried and because i'm obviously not a
really good boxer
uh maybe he's not very good there's
probably the
point just the vibes he was giving me
where there's probably a better chance
that that's the case than opposite
but i think this was just the
nervousness of a younger man who is less
secure
being around an older man who is secure
an accomplished mature person does not
feel humiliation
because he does not seek validation from
others ben askren chooses where he finds
his validation
his family his mission not legacy
not what others think about him we all
watch boxing and combat sports
not just for what it is but for what it
means after a fight with such a buildup
generally the outcome leaves one of the
fighters with a different attitude
but while ben was unhappy about the
results in the helwani interview you
could
see that he continued to maintain that
composure that is
he was genuinely unaffected by the
outcome
and when you look at ben askren's past
behavior it makes sense
ben never really cared what others
thought even when he was in the ufc
do you feel like you're doing this on
behalf of the fighting community the mma
community is this mma versus boxing is
this fighting versus youtube
are you taking that on your shoulders um
i don't know if i like the mma community
on a broader scale this fight meant
something for our culture because it was
a very public collision of forces you
usually don't see
the fight and all the build up to the
fight all the discussion the podcast
conversations
it's a story of a youthful internet
culture and its first meeting
through this fight with a more
established male culture
with its very different set of values
the culture of combat sports and martial
arts is about wisdom respect
reverence by contrast internet culture
is bursting with innovation and vital
energy
the very energy that's changing the
world around our eyes but its connection
to this
older culture and what came before it is
questionable because internet culture
just functions on its own references in
internet culture everything is a joke
and nothing is sacred
the phenomena of paul brothers in boxing
is a meeting of two different
generations and like all encounters
between
different peoples there is collaboration
and confrontation
so what did everyone learn i think the
old guard
learned to respect the new guard a lot
of people
especially older people thought of jake
paul as a youtuber
who comes from a fake online world they
thought he didn't earn anything real
i think his ko was a symbolic win that
said
what his generation has to offer is real
it has to be reckoned with
i also think the new guard learned to
respect the old guard
of course jake paul will keep trolling
but just think about how
ben asking dominated the public
relations war simply by keeping an
upbeat
honest champion mindset he went on the
enemies podcast logan paul's podcast and
made friends with everyone
that was actually a big deal in an era
where technology has led to
greater alienation amongst generations a
positive exchange between
cultures is no less than a step towards
reunification
of our modern world the paul brothers
are not going away
and neither is institution of combat
sports
this was round one we all look forward
to what round two brings
you want to really fight me you got an
issue with me
fight me in mixed martial arts and i'm
going to torture you
and i'm going to rip his face apart i'm
going to hurt the kid
and i will teach these kids not to
continue to do this
with people like me athletes that's
insane
this is